VANTACEK, THEY NEED GOALTENDING,
STABILIZATION AND THEY
SIDE STEP BACKSTROM.
TOSSED IN.
SUTER THE
CAPITALS CAN CAN NEVER SETTLE
DOWN.
ALMOST REMINISCENT
OFFSIDE, PRIOR TO THE SCORING OF
THE GOAL..
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MANY DANGER
POINTS ON THEIR POWER PLAY.
THEY RUN THEOUT.THER AS A PAIR.
FIFI POKES
FROM HAGELIN AND A FOURTH LINE
STAND.
>> THEY ARE FOURTHGHT.IN. FOR A
TIP ON THE
HAMMERED PAST THEM.
TAKE AWAY THE
HERE IS THE LEFT WING.
CAPITALS CONTINUNU WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU ARE .
PUCK IS  SAVED BY VANECEK, RIGHT
COVID, ETCETERA.
HE PLAYED ANOTHER FULL SEASON,
AND HE WOULD BE
FACE-OFFS.
LEAVES IT FOR SEGUIN.UIN.
>> MAN, WHAT A YEAR LAST YEAR. .
MADE TFOR A GOOD LOOK.
LINDELL,ONE DOWN HILL, S S IT I
PAVELSKI.
AND